thing is The Addams Family's pet and
servant whatever he is he plays a big
role in Netflix this Wednesday thing
steals the scene whenever he appears as
he's portrayed by Victor dorvontu he can
convey emotions through just his
movement you can tell when he's angry or
being smug he may be just a hand but his
physical mannerisms make him feel like a
whole person thing clearly cares about
Wednesday and his loyalty is unshakable
even when he doesn't agree with her
actions in the episode where Wednesday
finds thing impaled by a knife and
bleeding to death there's a palpable
tension thankfully Uncle Fester is able
to save thing using his electromagnetic
Powers but it's a close call thing is
not only Wednesday's partner in crime
he's also the voice of reason but only
in a metaphorical sense of course